why don't we go next to
oh I don't know how about David from
Regina Regina Saskatchewan
Regina actually is that true that's how
it's pronounced
yes it is actually there's a song online
called experience Regina Jimmy Fallon
actually has uh he's covered that before
but David welcome to the program
yeah thanks for having me um yeah I
guess my question today I've been you
know you had to call her a few weeks
back who was talking about uh gender and
and sex and I feel like something's
happening a lot where the right is
conflating these two things a lot right
like they don't understand the
difference between biological sex and
and gender expression right yep you know
while they're related they're not the
same thing so I guess my question is
like how the hell do we even start to
have that discussion right like I feel
like
we can't even have a discussion about
the issue without people understanding
what that even means if that makes sense
yeah I don't know like I I feel like so
the call in the call you're thinking of
I made an attempt to try to explain to
the caller who maybe was just unwilling
rather than unable to see I gave the
example of The Rock and then the fashion
designer Isaac Mizrahi and I think that
in a respectful way I explained you
understand these are both males right
we're talking about biological males
they were born male Etc we're talking
they're both male The Rock expresses
gender in a much more stereotypically
masculine way whereas Isaac Mizrahi uh
expresses gender in a much more feminine
way like you so the idea was to get him
to think okay right penis penis I see
that and then here's one presentation
and here's another presentation oh
there's more than just the genitalia
like I I tried you know I I think
sometimes it's it's like you've got to
use examples like that not to maybe get
them to think about these things but I
agree with you a lot of them do they
they don't seem to want to get it
honestly
well and that's just it right I think
and I think honestly like
if they would just take even just like
an introductory level course in like any
of these social science topics like
we've talked about this for decades and
decades and like there's not there's
really no debate about the difference
between these things anymore right so
but it's scary stuff like it has a real
impact and you know we're definitely
frightened up here in Canada watching
your Supreme Court do all these weird
things so
um yeah I hope I hope you guys can turn
that around with the next election for
sure well let's hope so we are I am on
board with uh with your now how is is
this an issue that's even really
discussed where you are or is it just
like people don't really talk about this
um you know I'm in Saskatchewan and
we're kind of the most right-wing place
in Canada so um like it's conservative
Haven here
um but as a country as a whole I I mean
it's discussed and there's like kind of
a fringe movement of people who want to
do the whole Mega thing here
um but I would say as a majority I don't
see that happening I don't see that
movement uh getting a lot of traction
um even even here in the conservative
kind of Bible Belt of Canada it's it's
while it's more popular here some of
these ideas they're still not getting
enough traction to like influence a lot
of policy and and that kind of thing so
I think I'm hoping we're safe I mean I I
knock on wood right so
I hope that that's the case David I
appreciate the call
yeah thanks for having me all right
great to hear from our friendly
neighbors to the north of course